les cambodgiens vont peut être enfin su
réconcilier grâce à leur homme
providentiel le principe nous acclamer
aujourd'hui par les siens après un exil
de 13 ans reportages des envoyés
spéciaux philippe pisteurs et philippe
jasselin le retour du prince se fait en
musique mais le tempo est soigneusement
réglé dès 8 heures ce matin tout le long
du parcours les petits orchestres
étaient en place que mes fonctionnaires
et les écoliers en congé pour l'occasion
soigneusement encadré les fanions aux
couleurs du cambodge s'agit devant les
caméras les banderole célébrant la fée
sont déployés 11 heures
les premiers pas du prince yannick 60
coben djia après douze ans d'absence
avec lui la princesse chronique sa femme
et le premier ministre une scène qui est
allé le chercher à pékin arrivée très
protocolaire accolades aux dignitaires
khmers suivi de l'hymne national
vient ensuite le salut au corps
diplomatique étranger aux militaires de
l'onu avant une courte cérémonie
le tout presque au pas de charge à peine
une demi-heure
la chevrolet impala modèle 63 attend le
prince départ de l'aéroport direction le
palais royal sur le bord de la route
tout le long du parcours les gens
attendent là depuis plus de trois heures
sous le soleil à me plaindre et leurs
voix aimait beaucoup les maintient pour
moi un parcours on va aller à toute
vitesse par le cortège l'arrivée au
palais royal
c'est fini